- Bonjour
- Alors je vous explique je réalise un documentaire sur les princes charmants d'aujourd'hui,
je vais commencer en vous demandant de me parler un peu de vous.
- Bah écoutez, moi...
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je vous dise,
c'est très simple moi mon quotidien c'est défonçage de dragon sauvetage de princesse tout ça...
- Oui bien sûr j'ai mon propre château,
c'est un petit 800m² sur forêt tout ce qu'il y'a de plus coquin en été...
- Bien sûr j'ai un cheval,
d'ailleurs le mien il fait du 100 km/h,
C'est-à-dire que dès qu'il y a un problème
[se claque les mains]
en 5 secondes je suis dessus.
- J'ai tué 4 dragons en tout, tu vois,
mais à chaque fois la princesse elle s'était barrée de sa tour du coup,
euh...
Ça servait à rien...
- J'ai besoin d'être tout le temps actif !
- Disons que quand je défonce pas des gobelins,
je défonce des dragons.
- Ouais ! Ouais je suis marrant ouais.
- Un prince ça a aussi besoin de se retrouver un peu seul face à soi-même...
c'est la solitude...
c'est la réflexion aussi...
- Enfin je me considère comme quelqu'un de marrant.
- Je me ballade la nuit...
Hop,
un enfant en danger !
Boum,
je saute dessus,
enfin par sur l'enfant on s'est bien compris hein.
- Le seul trésor que j'ai pas encore vraiment trouvé...
c'est l'amour.
- L'amour il va tomber sur moi quand il tombera sur moi...
Non je m'inquiète pas tu rigoles !
- Parce que tu vois une femme c'est fragile au final,
il faut la protéger il faut y faire attention.
- Mais pour moi c'est simple !
Il était une fois,
ils vécurent heureux et eurent beaucoup d'enfants,
c'est pas compliqué !
- Ça me fait grave plaisir de pouvoir parler avec toi comme ça parce que...
[inspire]
en temps normal j'arrive pas à parler aux femmes.
- Je me lève tous les jours à 14 heures.
- C'est toujours sale dans mon château...
- Je suis pas si marrant que ça
- Sauf quand il y a une fille qui vient là...
là je fais le ménage.
- Tu vois j'ai l'impression qu'il faut que je fasse des blagues tout le temps,
parce que sinon ça voudrait dire que je me prends trop au sérieux
et j'aime pas les gens qui se prennent trop au sérieux.
- Des fois je peux passer toute la journée dans mon château à jouer à la PS3
- J'ai peur d'étouffer les femmes que je rencontre en fait parce que...
je la vois direct comme la femme de ma vie et...
et ça c'est flippant...
- Elle ont aussi vachement changé les princesses faut dire c'qui est !
- On m'a tellement pas appris à pas être un macho aussi,
du coup je me laisse marcher sur les pieds par toutes les meufs que je rencontre tu vois...
parce que j'ai peur de les perdre...
- Avant chaque rendez-vous je me branle
pour pas être stressé...
[silence]
d'ailleurs je me suis branlé avant de venir...
- Ça serait quand même super chaud de sortir avec Mérida quoi...
déjà parce que elle tire vachement mieux à l'arc que moi.
- Je deviens facilement trop dépendant parce que je pense que...
j'aime pas ce que je suis au fond...
et que je préfère me fondre...
en l'autre...
- J'ai jamais utilisé mon épée...
- J'ai pas de cheval en fait...
je suis venu à pied.
- J'ai peur de finir tout seul...
[silence]
comme tout le monde.
- Et bah merci de votre participation et puis de votre honnêteté surtout.
De rien c'était...
j'espère que c'était bien.
Ah...
- Bah tu vois c'est ça que je te disais en faite
j'ai l'impression qu'il faut que je fasse une blague là
parce que sinon c'est une ambiance un peu trop sérieuse et tout tu vois
que si au final si je fais pas de blague
c'est juste...
c'est juste triste tu vois...
Excusez-moi
je viens de me faire 4 dragons pour sauver une meuf.
C'est pour quoi l'interview ?